Welcome back everyone this is going to be my new
marvel henry cavill captain britain video you
may have seen the news recently he's talking all
about captain britain i'll explain what's going on
because there's a big connection to what was going
on in the eternals movie with the black knight
in that mythology so if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
marvel's disney plus day is happening now i'm
going to be doing videos for all the big trailers
they release so make sure you enable alerts
for my channel so you don't miss any of those
and i will be doing giveaways for disney plus
memberships in those videos but recently you
may have seen the news henry cavill talking about
doing captain britain in the marvel movies it was
part of this larger interview where he was talking
about all of his upcoming projects in some of the
things that he's been pushing for he also talked
about doing new superman movies and commented on
all the different versions of superman that
dc has coming up so i'll address that after i
talk about the marvel captain britain stuff just
because that's a little more relevant to what's
happening this week with all the eternal stuff
coming out the interviewer was asking him about
which marvel characters he would want to play
because everyone's been wondering for the past
couple of years since it seems like superman isn't
such a huge priority for dc if he would pack up
and head to marvel and play a marvel character you
may remember all those silly rumors after avengers
end game about him becoming the new version of
marvel's wolverine but here's what he said about
becoming captain britain during marvel phase 4
marvel phase 5. he said bean captain britain would
be loads of fun to do cool modernized version of
that like the way they modernized captain america
steve rogers captain america there's something fun
about that and i do love being british so this was
like a pretty big interview it was him sort of
letting marvel know hey i'm interested be sure to
call me if they haven't already called him about
playing a character when it comes to stuff like
that marvel has meetings with everybody all the
time they've met with keanu reeves about playing
characters during every major phase of movies way
back in marvel phase one phase two phase three
kevin feige said it's actually pretty normal for
them to do stuff like that but what he's talking
about is doing captain britain set in present
day think like henry cavill in man from uncle
or during the mission impossible movies that sort
of modern day type of hyperkinetic action but with
him running around swinging a sword and speaking
of fantasy based characters most of you might
remember henry cavill before he became superman in
the man of steel movie in the dc movies he played
a british lord during the tudors series swinging
a sword around and most of you have been watching
him as geralt the witcher on the witcher netflix
so everyone toss a coin to your captain britain
when he says modernized the main version of
captain britain brian braddock was created in
the 1970s so a lot of the adventures that he had
traded on major pop culture events of that era
that's also why they had that really cool
avengers end game easter egg for captain britain
during the time heist mission to the 1970s when
iron man and captain america went back to camp
lehigh in the 1970s to steal the tesseract captain
america is searching the offices for pym particles
to steal so they can return back to present
day he stumbles into an office only to see that
it's peggy carter's shield office on the base and
they play for this really dramatic moment he gets
really sad thinking about how much he loves her
and as he watches her walk in from the other side
of the glass trying to stay hidden she mentions
agent braddock and that's meant to be a reference
for brian braddock who became captain britain in
the 1970s and even though this is a very captain
america kind of scene captain britain is not just
a british version of captain america he doesn't
have the whole man out of time thing going for
him being from the 1940s frozen in ice for over
70 years when he was created he was meant to
be a character from present day who was just
part of this ancient line kind of like the black
knight but speaking of peggy carter talking about
that avengers endgame scene during the what if
episodes that i did videos for recently we kind of
got a multiverse version of peggy carter captain
britain with the costume but the way they played
the character she was more like captain america
just wearing a captain britain looking costume
than being a straight up captain britain just
because his backstory is so different from captain
america's backstory in my opinion it was a big
missed opportunity for some cool easter eggs the
big connection to the eternals movie so captain
britain's backstory is a little bit like dane
whitman's black knight backstory kit harrington's
going to be playing in the mcu now it trades
very heavily on the king arthur mythology british
legends magic and characters like merlin traveling
through time and the multiverse so spoiler warning
for the eternals movie if you haven't seen it
yet because we have to talk about some big black
knight plot points during the eternals movie when
the eternals go back to the domo their spaceship
and present day they find that makkari has been
living there for centuries while they've all been
living apart and over that time she's collected
hint stolen many priceless artifacts from across
history and all the adventures that they had when
they were still together while they're having
fun picking through her piles of treasure fina
picks up a sword swinging it around remembering
the period of history where they all lived in
camelot together with king arthur lancelot merlin
and the knights of the round table and sprite asks
her if the sword she's playing with is the ebony
blade which is a huge black knight easter egg
because the original black knight comes from
camelot in the ebony blade was forged by merlin
but then thena says no it's excalibur like the
legendary excalibur given to arthur by the lady in
the lake meaning that all those legends were real
historical events in the mcu like king arthur was
a real person in big doctor strange connection
merlin was the sorcerer supreme of his era
but bringing it back around to all the magical
swords while the black knight wields the ebony
blade captain britain wields excalibur for a
brief period and we just saw excalibur in the
eternals movie as well as the ebony blade in that
post-credits scene most of the time though captain
britain's main weapons are the amulet of right in
the sword of might just like kit harington's dane
whitman black knight brian braddock's captain
britain comes from a powerful british family
that goes back to the middle ages his father
was the previous version of captain britain
and when a new captain britain is selected merlin
and his daughter roma come to the new candidate
and offer them a choice between the amulet and the
sword is sort of a test of character like the holy
grail test in indiana jones in the last crusade
choosing the amulet represents the path of reason
while the sword represents the path of violence
generally merlin tends to favor the people who
choose the amulet like you have chosen wisely but
you can still choose the path of violence like
pick the sword and become the next captain britain
the amulet and the sword are super powerful but
unlike the black knight he doesn't only get his
powers from the blade or the amulet most of his
abilities are powered by interdimensional energies
which are concentrated around the british isles
and other world other world is this pocket
dimension next to earth where avalon exists from
the king arthur mythology is this realm of really
powerful magic where merlin lives when he's not
running around the main marvel universe captain
britain's costume also kind of serves as a tether
to this magical feel that he draws his energy from
but basically his powers are similar to captain
america's powers in that he has enhanced strength
stamina durability speed but the amulet he wears
also gives him a limited ability to fly at
this point in marvel phase 4 we're trading
very heavily on multiverse tropes like we had
the loki series with the kang multiverse war
we have doctor strange multiverse of madness
we have spider-man no way home which is a very
spider-verse multiverse type of story the captain
britain's stories especially the more recent ones
trade heavily on multiverse tropes you may
remember a couple years ago after avengers
end game came out there were a couple rumors
that we would see a version of captain britain
in the upcoming movies i think the idea right now
is that they're doing kit harington's black knight
character first as sort of a lead into the more
mystical fantasy based sword and sorcery marvel
stories and once they figure that out like how to
make it game of thrones but said in present day
with him crossing over with all the avengers
and avengers 5 without it feeling silly or weird
and then they'll start doing more of those type
of fantasy based characters because there is a
lot of that inside the marvel canon i'm also
really hoping for a kit harington black knight
disney plus series since they can use the extra
episodes in room to just flesh out all that king
arthur mythology and backstory that they teased
during the eternals movie and introduced the
mcu merlin and explained the history of the ebony
blade and how the eternals were connected all that
the whole idea being that merlin being sorcerer
supreme of his era would be knowledgeable enough
to understand that the eternals were not human so
even if king arthur didn't know what was going on
with that merlin probably knew what was up with
the eternals just in terms of when we would see a
version of captain britain in the mcu it probably
wouldn't be till after they fully develop kit
harington's black knight character and it sounds
like we're gonna see him wielding the ebony blade
being full-blown black knight during marvel's
blade movie at some point the way they teased him
crossing over in that post-credit scene so it'll
be at least a couple years before they figure all
that stuff out leaving henry cavill plenty of time
to return as superman in new dc movies for all
you hoping that he comes back as superman which he
said he's very much trying to do in this interview
he has been trying to get a new man of steel movie
going for a couple years now but because dc has
so many superman related projects with different
versions of the character coming up it sounds
like at best we'll probably just see henry cavill
superman crossovers and cameo scenes for the next
couple of years but i'll do separate videos for
all those dc movies and superman projects when
they release trailers speaking of trailers it is
like trailer city this weekend marvel's disney
plus day is here they will start releasing all
those trailers really soon of course i'll do
videos for everything make sure you have alerts
enabled for my channel so you don't miss any of
those the obi-wan kenobi trailer just leaked this
morning so i'll do a full video for that when they
release it officially here's a quick teaser from
it of obi-wan versus darth vader in their rematch
fight hayden christensen came back as darth vader
for this he's also coming back during the ahsoka
series as well everyone click here for all my
disney plus trailer videos i'll update the link
as soon as i start posting them and click here
for my full eternals post credit scene video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!